[UPBEAT MUSIC]
ANDRE KELLY: Everyone
knows the story, right?
It's 2:00 AM.
Your pager goes off.
And you have to figure out
what went wrong, right?
How do you get back to
having happy customers?
And more importantly, how do
you get back to sleep, right?
And I'm sure most people--
some people in here
have definitely gone through
that experience, right?
So a little about myself.
My name is Andre Kelly,
and I'm the product manager
for Stackdriver Incident
Response and Management,
shortly called just IRM.
And today, we're going to talk
about a kind of new frontier,
I call it, in the space
of incident response, what
I refer to as data management.
And the objective is, how can
we use it to get more sleep?
And so we'll discuss
today the technology
that GCP has developed or
has started and is developing
that enables this
technology and this ability
and really work toward
division of fewer, shorter,
and smaller outages.
That's what we're
working towards.
So just a quick rundown of
what we're going to go through,
just the lifecycle
overall of an incident,
kind of calibrate everyone.
Process management is kind of an
interesting component to this.
We're going to go for that
real quickly, high level.
And then we're going to dive
a little deeper into the data
management as I see it,
and the future of it,
what we can do there, what
the benefits are, and then get
to the fun stuff.
We're going to demo IRM and look
at some of the data management
functionality we
have in IRM today.
And then we're going to wrap up.
Time willing, we're going
to take some questions.
So I want to keep
it interactive,
so let's get started.
So lifecycle.
So I think it's very
important to highlight this,
that incidents are inevitable.
We're all going to have them.
No matter the amount of
auto healing and anything
that we put together,
it's bound to happen.
And I think it's important to
appreciate that and recognize
that, because that enables us
to then plan for that case.
What can we do?
What things are in place?
What processes do we
have to put in place
to make sure we can
respond appropriately?
And that's a key part of how
we do incident management
at Google.
So just a quick rundown of a
very simplified, admittedly,
view of the internet lifecycle--
where things start and
where things end up.
Usually, there's a
root cause event.
And usually, it's-- high
percentage, 70% or something--
if these are based on change--
change in code,
change in config,
some other activity
causing a problem.
That leads to some
kind of detection.
So either a human detects
it or your cloud support.
Your support team tells you.
Or an automated detection
system detects it.
But then soon after,
some human, hopefully,
is aware of the problem,
and that starts a response.
So usually, it's some
initial diagnosis
as to how bad the problem
is and what's going on.
And then the meat
of the activity
happens in this investigation.
And what typically goes on there
is that you're gathering data,
and the human is doing some
kind of correlation process
to figure out what's wrong.
So you can figure out the
best action to mitigate.
After some sign of
successful mitigation,
we then sometimes fork into how
do we capture lessons learned.
And a very traditional process.
Bigger cases is something
like a postmortem.
In some cases, it
can be smaller.
And I'll go through some
of those more lightweight
processes of how that can be
helpful of captured lessons
learned.
And then the resolved
state that we call it,
it's really about
fixing that bug.
So we mitigated the problem.
That doesn't mean we
actually fixed the bug.
That could be something
as quick as a rollback.
But then the actual bug
fix could take days.
It could take involvement
with several teams.
So you want to make
that a different stage.
But that's really kind
of outside the scope
of what I consider
the tooling that we're
going to talk about today
in incident response.
IRM doesn't want to be a tool
that is doing code changes,
and config changes, and so on.
We recognize it as
part of the lifecycle,
but we don't want to be
involved in actual directly
that activity.
And that's why that's a
little bit different in color.
But it's key to
recognize that we
don't consider the incident
done until all those stages are
complete.
And that connection of
that lifecycle is key,
and you can extract a lot of
interesting elements and data
from that to help future things.
And that's one of the key parts
of the data management idea.
So let's take it
a little further.
So just to cover some
more elements here.
I typically break down
incident lifecycle
into three major pillars.
One is people management.
And this, I think, many
are probably familiar with.
This is the on-call rotation
kind of setup, the schedule.
How do you get the right
alert to the right person.
This part of the people, getting
that first kind of notification
to the human, that component,
that's what this covers here.
Now we are not doing this
because there's a lot of--
sorry.
Let me rephrase that.
We are not directly
investing in this right
now, because there's a
lot of great existing
tools in the marketplace
that cover that.
However, where Google
has a lot of expertise
from our various years
in incident response is
in process management,
efficient ways
to coordinate and command
an incident and make sure
there's no gaps or
overlaps in their response.
And this emerged from the
emergency response system
that came out in the '70s from
firefighting that happened here
in California.
And so we adapted
that for the IT space,
using the similar
structure pyramid
of roles and responsibilities.
And we'll go into
that a little bit
and how that fits
into the tooling.
And the last place that
is the newer item in IC,
and this is the data management.
And this is going to elaborate
more what I mean by that.
In today's system, especially
in Stackdriver and GCP,
there's a wealth
of data available.
We have metrics.
We have logs.
We have traces.
We have profile information.
There's a wealth of data
available the user can, when
an alert fires,
possibly can look at.
So the question is, how
can the system itself
help you manage that
data, so you can maximize
your [INAUDIBLE] investigation?
If there's a path
of investigation,
how can we leapfrog you in data
points down that investigation?
We mentioned earlier,
that investigation period
is about gathering data
and doing that correlation.
So how can we do some
correlation for you,
and then jump you
along that path
that you're going
to do as a human?
And leave the tougher
analysis that humans
do so well that computers
still struggle at for you.
And that's one of the
key elements of it.
And then data in the
other senses as well.
So the data in terms
of, when you first
start to respond, how do we
make it so that we maximize
your situational
awareness, so you become
aware of what the problem
is, what's the blast
radius, and so on.
And then how do we
manage that data
that's what you track as
your response over time,
so you can be more
efficient in the future?
So all these pieces
of data, we're
talking about existing
ops data, information
about the system
of GCP, and data
that you're adding
into the system.
As a human, curating
that data is important.
So just a quick back
and forth for a second,
talk about the process
management element.
It's important to review
what Google's view of this is
and then how data
management slots into that.
So first, it's Incident
Management at Google.
You might hear this called IMAG.
It's mentioned in
the two SRE books,
and it's really the protocol
we use inside Google
for incident response.
Now a quick mention about IRM.
IRM is, internally, the next
generation incident response
tool for Google to use in
its early response system.
So we're replacing about at
least three tools and a couple
of hanger-off tools as
well, consolidating that
into one tool.
We're providing that
same tooling externally
through Stackdriver
as IRM as-is.
I want to get to the
demo, because that's
all the exciting stuff.
But what that tool
then provides is
years of battle-tested processes
that cover three main things.
And this is the process part.
So one, the idea
of coordination,
the idea that you need to
be able to recognize roles
and-- sorry, not roles.
Yeah, so roles and
responsibilities.
So that idea I mentioned
several times of,
we don't want gaps or
overlaps in effort.
The SRE books, the
workbook especially,
talks about the
idea of, if someone
is responding to an
incident, and someone else,
with all good intentions,
says, oh, I can help,
and they jump in and they
start doing something
but the other person has
no idea what's going on,
that can actually
make things worse.
So you need to establish
this idea and practice
that, as a team, we're going to
respond to incidents this way.
We're going to know
who's going to do what.
And we know who is in
charge in terms of their--
typically, called the
incident commander.
So it's important to have
these processes in place.
And this goes back to
the idea of saying,
an incident is going to happen.
Even if you typically don't
have a long history of them,
you've got to have
a process in place.
So when it does, you can
get back to happy customers
and back to sleep, possibly.
I'm really into sleep.
You can tell.
Second part is communication.
And just from life,
we know communication
is super-important.
But in internet management,
it goes to that same thing.
In that case or scenario
of someone was responding
and that good-intentioned
colleague wants to jump in,
they could jump in.
They need to communicate
with someone.
They should know to go
to the incident commander
and say, hey, I can help out.
I know this system.
And they could be granted
a role to help out.
So it's about communication,
and it's several levels
of communication.
So one, within the team.
At the lowest level
of the response, who's
doing what in the response.
And then you need to
communicate outside the team,
within your organization.
So many times, VPs
want to know when
something public is going on.
If your thing is on Twitter
with some bad feedback,
some VP starts going, hey, man,
what's going on with this issue
that I'm seeing?
And so you want to keep them
informed, but not just informed
when they ping
you-- proactively.
You don't want them on
your back as you're trying
to respond to the incident.
And so part of the IMAG system
is actually sharpening up
the role of the activities of
who's responding to the problem
and who's actually
communicating,
and then who's actually
commanding as well.
And so you can start to see a
separation of responsibilities
and how they all work
together in concert.
And then the third level, if
the incident tends to need it,
is communicating
outside the organization
through your support
channels, or through Twitter,
or through your
status dashboard.
Telling your customers
what's going on.
Because otherwise,
they get antsy,
and you erode that well-built
goodwill and trust.
So this is all
part of that idea.
And lastly, the
idea of control--
the sense that you have to
keep up with what's going on
and be mindful of the scope
and impact of the incident.
And so this is bigger, a lot
of the role of the incident
commander to say, hey,
do we need more people?
I have a com lead, and
I've got an ops lead.
But, man, this thing is
really getting out of control.
Do I need to get
more people involved?
In the protocol-- and
this works at Google,
but you have to work with
your team to see if it works--
a commander could ask your boss
to become part of the incident.
And the commanders then
telling their boss what to do.
It's not about hierarchy.
It's about the process and
about working in that moment
to solve the problem.
So that's the idea
behind control--
being mindful of that and
trying to address the problem.
I mentioned here in the
slide about heroics.
It shouldn't take
heroics whenever
an incident comes around to get
you back to happy customers.
That should be the exception.
It should be orderly that you're
not extending your workday.
So that means a clean shift
handoff and an orderly process
with that.
So the commander
goes, you know what?
Man, it's 5 o'clock.
I got dinner plans
with my family.
I need to find a new
incident commander
and hand off the process.
And that should be an orderly
process, and that's part of it
as well.
That should be built
into the process.
So I wasn't sure how good
people could see this.
Can people in the back
see this all right?
No?
Not at all?
OK, thank you for that feedback.
[LAUGHTER]
I tell you what.
We'll look at one for the
demo, the data management.
I'll switch over to
another incident that
has some of this-- this
is kind of filled out,
but I'll try to get you
the same information.
But just by regional
areas, the things
I just talked about in terms
of the processes and elements
are reflected here.
This incident, I recreated
it from the SRE Workbook.
I don't know how many of
you are familiar with it,
but in Belgium,
a couple of years
ago, we had four lightning
strikes at a data center.
And some batteries,
the UPS acted funny
because of four
lightning strikes.
Who would have thought, right?
And so some disks went
weird, and some disks
became non-operational.
It required restarting
and this whole process
to get things back online.
In the data center, so
people were being impacted.
And so this is recapping,
capturing the roles that
were involved as described in
the postmortem, information
that people referenced,
and then who
were trying to be communicated
and informed about.
So in the lower right-hand,
you see subscriptions.
That's the outbound
communication to stakeholders,
so they're aware
of what's going on
before they start pinging you.
On the left here at
the bottom is a link.
So these are links to playbooks.
And what they found
out in the incident
was that we have
no process of how
to batch restart a bunch
of VMs and disks together.
We don't know how to do it.
[INAUDIBLE] before.
So there was a process of
establishing scripts and docs
and trying to capture
that information.
There was a process that we
started, I think, one or two.
But the scale of
the problem needed
a whole different
extension of that process.
So new docs spun
up to capture that.
So this is kind of a way of
tracking that information.
And then the top there
is the summary capturing
the status, the impact,
and the next update.
So if you're a stakeholder.
You come by the
incident and say, OK,
let me see what's going on
beyond what they're saying.
You have a human-readable--
sorry, let me rephrase that.
You have a in plain
English readable
way, a summary of the problem
and not technical jargon
saying, I'm running
this command.
And this is going on.
But I can read that there's
this problem going on
and so on and so forth.
It's meant to be about
consuming the data, not about
the details.
There is a different section
of the app that's for that.
You also see that,
in the upper right,
there's a sense of the
severity and also a comms room.
So for the low-level
responders, their details,
they're able to actually click
in and see all the stream
of data in that locker room.
For us, it was IRC.
So it has the mechanisms for
you to quickly get more data
and get a snippet of data,
and move on, and structure
that information.
And this is about the observer
view and the incident commander
view of the incident and where
they would stay and manage
information.
There's other sections meant
for the operators that are
more detailed at a lower level.
And the data management
part, we'll go into,
that shows you,
when you get started
what information is
available for you
and how we structure
that to get started.
So with that, let's talk
about data management then.
We talked about, initially,
coordinate, communication,
and control, the three
Cs of the IMAG process.
So data management,
with our push,
this brings in two more Cs.
So now we're up to five Cs.
And first in that--
wait, sorry, that
didn't go there, OK--
is context.
What can we do with the data
information available to us
to make sure that
when you first start,
you have the best
context to get started
in terms of
situational awareness
and continue that as you go?
So not just as you start,
but maintain that information
in the context of the incident
to everything that we do.
And then I mentioned a framework
to collect human-curated data
as part of that process.
And then the fifth is--
I'm cheating by saying C
here-- but autocorrelation.
Not only are we looking for
data just to show the user,
but can be correlate it with
other activities in the system
in the environment?
And especially at
GCP and Stackdriver,
where we're also your cloud
provider and your monitoring
system.
If you have an incident
response tool on this layer,
there's additional
data that we have
that others may
not have available.
And over the past several
years, for example,
Google has worked on--
one of our sister teams--
has worked together in GCP
DevOps that maps and collects
relationship data between
different entities
and resources
throughout environments.
So we see communication data.
We can see config changes.
And this data is
resource to resource
and expanding over time.
And so that gives
us the raw data
to correlate and
work on identifying
failure patterns that we
can raise and highlight
to the user.
We'll visualize this
technology in a demo later on.
But just to highlight what
that raw information is,
and what we're doing,
and the benefit
of combining that vertical
integration of cloud
provider monitoring system and
incident response together.
OK, so what does this get us?
So one, I mentioned, we're
working for fewer outages.
And how does that work?
With an end-to-end
lifecycle, we want
to make sure that, as you're
finding bugs and following up
action items that you're able to
connect it to, actually, what's
the service that keeps
triggering these things?
What's the service that keeps
putting me at false positives?
What's an alert pause
I need to work on?
Can we start connecting
that end symptom
with the causal, structural
thing that needs attention?
Everyone, I'm sure, in
this room has had a case,
where an incident happened when
we knew we had a follow-up bug
to do that would fix, that
would address the problem,
but we just didn't get to it.
So how can we highlight
those situations
better, so that the riskiest
items actually gets attention
from management for investment?
Sometimes a rearchitecture is
needed to solve the problem.
So how can we show over the
past 30 days or whatever,
or past two quarters that
our biggest outages were
caused by the same service?
Connecting those things
together is actually
the key part of that in
data management and lead
to fewer outages.
Second is the idea
of shorter outages.
And this goes to the two key
pillars of the idea of the data
management and IRM.
And that's the idea of context
and continuous learning,
that through automated ways
and through low-friction ways,
users are able to input
data that we can then
leverage for future occurrences,
so that the time to more
valuable information
and understanding
the current situation
gets shorter and shorter.
Now I threw numbers out
there for appreciation,
not necessarily this is
exactly what would happen.
But we want to make
sure that each time
that you're having
the same alert fire,
and it's a similar
situation, then
it should take you less time.
A system should help you learn.
You don't have to be
the same responder
to actually benefit
from the previous time
that you addressed this issue.
Then there's also the
case of postmortems.
So postmortems are
a very common way
to capture, traditionally,
lessons learned.
But I bet, if I polled this
room on how many people actually
did postmortems, it'd
be quite a low ratio.
It's like vegetables, right?
Everyone knows
they're good for you,
but nobody actually eats them.
No one eats them enough.
I'll put it that way.
This is my weird joke now.
We're trying to be the ranch
dressing for those vegetables,
so for postmortems.
How do we get you to create more
postmortems with less effort?
How can we take that data that
we identified and you curated,
put it together, and generate
the majority of that postmortem
together?
So those are the things
we're working towards.
And then lastly,
smaller outages.
So this is the example
of a correlation,
and we'll go through a live one.
This is the example of the
insight that we'll do--
correlating a learning metric
with a metric in your system
that's related to it.
And so while correlation
insights are important,
most importantly,
we want to make sure
that we're focused on this
information at the right stage
of the lifecycle.
And when the incident
starts, the focus
there should be mitigation,
not root cause analysis.
Sometimes people fall
into that trap of saying,
oh, let me go find that
line of the bug that's
causing the problem when a
rollback could be faster.
We want to make sure
that we're providing
data that helps information
that targets you
to mitigate the problem
and stop what we usually
call the trigger.
So the code might be the
bug, but a deployment
was the trigger or the
redirection of traffic
from the config was the trigger.
How do we identify
those events so
that you can stop the impact to
your users as fast as possible?
And then later, once
we've mitigated,
recognize that event,
and then switch
to information that's
more focused and helpful
to do the resolution.
So understanding those stages
of the lifecycle elements,
and what that flow looks like,
and point your information data
focused to each of
those at the time.
So with that,
let's go do a demo.
I'm going to have to do a
little bit of gymnastics here
to get to the right thing,
but we should be all right.
So before I started the
talk, I did something
at the Hipster Shop.
Anybody familiar
with Hipster Shop?
It's the most commonly
broken app ever.
But we ticked off something
that caused a problem.
And so here in
our Slack channel,
we now get an alert
saying something
happened to Hipster Shop.
So let's take a look what would
happen in terms of what you
get in IRM based on that alert.
So this is a live demo, so
may be a little bit janky.
I mentioned,
Stackdriver is an alpha.
So if you see any
bruises or short things,
it's because it's alpha,
but available to sign up.
Let's talk about it afterwards.
So here, in terms of
context, what do we provide?
So we know it's slow firing.
We have a chart
of the volumetric.
Immediately we see
that, yep, it went up
around the time of the alert.
It's still up.
What's going on there?
We can then see that we have
an insight that triggered.
When the latency
went up, the CPU
shot up for this pod
contained at the same time
or right before,
and then sustained.
So it could be related.
So we're not promising that
we're identifying root cause
directly, but we're trying to
jump you down or leapfrog you
down that investigation
path that you're going
to follow naturally anyway.
So this is key information
that you could use immediately.
Now there's also links here to
tools, like metric explorer.
And metric explorer
gives you a way
to kind of slice and dice data.
And this link is a link
that will convey the context
of the incident into that tool.
So we would preload the metric
of the correlated metric
to the time of the
incident, and then you
can start adjusting things.
So one useful scenario
here is that, if you have,
let's say, a fleet of VMs or
GKE clusters in different zones
and you have an alert
happening, you could then
use metric explorer to
quickly slice and dice
your data to see
if it's centered
to one zone or one region.
Maybe it's one region,
and you can just drain it.
So it's about
conveying the problem
that you're having
into the tools
that you use for your ops
navigation rather than you,
as a human, starting
from scratch each time.
Same thing applies here
to these log links.
So this is a link to
logs that would reduce
the time of the logs
for the last 30 minutes
around the time of the incident
based on the resource it is.
And for log-based metrics,
we then also apply the query.
So we are filtering it down
to exactly what was related
to populating and triggering
that incident-- or that alert,
sorry.
And same thing,
metric explorer here,
we would jump to the chart of
the alerting metric populated
with that information.
So that's the data
in a situation
that we have to
provide immediately
upon arriving on the page.
So that's a typical improvement.
We then go further down.
This is a duplicate of
the metric correlation,
so just ignore that.
We then go down and you
see that hey, actually,
there's some similar
incident that
happened similar to this
alert that's firing right now.
And we can see the
information that's there.
We see cause tags that--
you guys can't-- can
you guys read that?
I'll read it out.
So there's cause tags on each--
cause bug, cause experiment,
and cause config.
So three different
causes that happened.
Ignore the time.
This is because of me preparing,
so it all happened yesterday.
This is an unrealistic
map, that sense.
But the actions
were all different.
Sorry.
The actions were all the same.
So three different causes, but
the actions were all the same.
So that gives you an
indicator that, for this kind
of alert, typically, you
can solve the problem
with a failover.
So just upon
arriving on the page,
based on what people
did the last time,
I don't have to go find
the postmortem in some doc
somewhere or some email
and figure it out.
I wasn't the person
on call, but I
have this history and
knowledge now baked
into the tool at my fingertips
in the context of the incident
that's happening right now.
So that's what we're aiming for.
In this particular
case, I could see
that, also, the first
two are resolved,
and the other one
is only mitigated.
So maybe there's something
that is still going on there,
or someone's still
working on it.
But we know that users
are no longer impacted.
So it's just a context.
And we also see the severity
of these examples as well.
So for this case, I'm going
to then start investigating.
So I see that, given
the CPU correlation,
this is the usual--
this is a little
unusual, because I
have to write 10 feet
apart from my eyes.
All right.
So that's just part
of the key core data
when you get started in
front of the data management
idea that's possible--
leveraging data from different
systems and also the ability
to framework data out.
I mentioned this idea of
leveraging the same framework
for human-curated data.
So in this section here of
the investigation update,
right now, it's
very heavily taxed.
But the next thing
we're going to do here
is capture the actual ops
data you want to look at.
So instead of saying
and noting here
that I looked at chart
blah-blah-blah metric
in container
blah-blah-blah, instead,
through Stackdriver dashboard,
you push the chart to IRM.
And so this would be a
screenshot presented here
of the chart used.
But not only that, we would
capture the metadata of that
chart you looked at.
So in that previous
page, not only then
we have the data for you.
We would show you the chart.
If you always went to that
chart when this kind of alert
happened, we would just
show you the chart.
So this is the kind of
way you can leverage
data for the actual
incident response process
throughout very common
production cases.
I wanted to go
through the overview.
Can you guys see that better
now than the picture before?
OK, yeah?
OK.
So let's say I was--
let me do best practice.
Best practice is when you start
responding to the severity.
I think this is minor.
I don't really know but--
and this is a couple
of information
here about the process
elements and tools of IRM.
So here's a case, where
we're providing descriptions
of severities to
help the consistency
across different team members.
So everyone is trying
to be as close as
possible to the same thing,
describing the same situation
Let's say this was a minor.
You can always update later.
So don't be shy about
setting the severity
and updating it
later is my rule.
I'll set comms to
something in Slack.
Something.
And then, let's say that
during my investigation,
I realized that, actually,
this is bigger than I thought.
This is actually
quite substantial.
This is where you want to
engage that protocol of, oh, I
need coordination.
I need an actual
incident commander.
So right now, I'm just
a single responder.
It's just me who is
the nearest right now.
But let's get some
more people involved.
What I want to do
to kick that off
is I want to escalate
the incident.
So right now, this is a local
incident in my local team.
But this idea of
escalating, have
you guys heard of OMG,
that tool called OMG?
Yeah?
So escalating an
incident is kind
of the parallel of getting to
an OMG level incident, where
everyone in the company
can go to one place
and see it and see
what's going on.
And with that process is
this notion of a preset.
So I mentioned the idea of
incidents are inevitable,
and you want to plan for them.
So here's a case where product
catalog service is just
a weird thing.
But if it gets impacted,
it slows down our shoppers.
It's a known thing.
So we prepared a preset
just for product log server,
product catalog.
You might do it on
different dimensions.
But for this example, we're
just going to do it that way.
And so I'm going to
apply that preset.
So you see that the
current severity is minor,
and there's very little
information in other fields.
But by setting that alone,
and then hitting Escalate--
so it's a couple of clicks--
I populated it with the
playbooks and the links.
I identified
subscriptions for VPs
and others that are
typical stakeholders that
want to know what's going on
when product log service goes
down.
Because typically, it's low.
We know that its
impact is on quality,
because our users will start
thinking that, hey, this
is weird.
And that's a very
lightweight way
to give lessons learned,
through the structure of tags.
The most common ones
are cause and action.
You saw that on a previous page.
But here, we action the tag of
impact just to kind of quickly
capture that.
And we've added some
templating to the summary now.
So now, we want to
know we want to capture
the current status in terms
of, is it user visible?
Or is it degraded service?
But these are just examples.
You just want to capture a
template that everyone can do.
So depending on your
preset or your team,
you might have particular
formation you want to know,
like how many users, or
which regions, and so on.
So this is an easy way
to kind of structure
a summary, like we
mentioned, to be
very plain English information.
And then a key
information we want to do,
which, at this stage,
is just a plain text,
but will be a structured
information to be a countdown.
When is the next update?
How old is the thing
you just saved to me.
When will I get an update
on what's going on?
Typically, for
some that's major--
so we're just up to major now--
it could be, like, 30
minutes or 20 minutes.
If it's huge, you want to go
to 15 minutes or something.
So that's one way to quickly
turn up the gas on a response.
And then I would
go in and say, OK,
let's add some
people to this role.
I want to get an
incident commander.
I don't know if my
colleague is here.
And then he could go on,
and then add in a comms lead
and so on.
But I'm the primary responder.
At this stage, I would
change to the ops lead
and continue to
debug the process.
Team would come in and then
start adding a comms lead,
perhaps an external
communications
lead to make sure
we're communicating
with the external
world, and start
slotting into those
processes and roles
of the different elements.
OK?
So that was the heart of
the demo I wanted to give.
So one thing to kind
of nail home the point
of what IRM's vision is,
and that's really about,
I mentioned, the fewer, shorter,
and smaller outages and working
towards that, leveraging
data management.
So there's lots of
potential in this approach,
but there's a great
foundation in place.
We plan to build on
top of that in IRM
to help our users reduce their
median time to mitigation.
And love your feedback.
And so in the Cloud
Next app, please rate
and provide feedback.
It'd be great, so the next
talk I do will be better.
So with that, I'm
going to call it.
Thank you, guys, so much for
coming out and hanging around.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
[UPBEAT MUSIC]